[Music]
no gifts
my job is to
speak to clients um on the phone about
uh quantities and uh
type of
copier paper
you know uh whether we can supply it to
them whether they can uh
pay for it
and um
i'm i'm boring myself just talking about
this
detectives i see we got eight recruits
for the junior police program
outstanding thank you sir
but as important as your praise is to me
it should actually go to gina she's the
one that got through to the kids yes i
am amazing and i only asked for one
thing in repayment
a 600 raise or i could give you a zero
percent raise and make you my personal
assistant which is what i'm doing i
think you have hidden talents which will
make you surprisingly good at the job no
i have no talents you start monday
ugh
constantly getting hult's approval is
the worst yes i can only imagine
parks and
rec confirming what
that's not possible
oh no
hey good morning why are there six
people outside who say they're waiting
to meet with me so you know how you love
me because you haven't had a single
meeting with anyone since i became your
assistant that's because
every time someone calls and requests a
meeting with you i always schedule it
for march 31st
why because i didn't think march 31st
existed
30 days has september april march and
november june and november
today is march 31st i know so then how
many meetings do i have today
93.
okay okay well
you know what to do
right
to me
this situation is a blood-soaked
nightmarish hellscape
however to leslie knope oh how fun
yay why don't you take as many as you
can and i'll cover the rest i have a
better idea why don't i try to rustle up
seven more meetings cause i think it
would be cooler if there were an even
100. why don't we just stick to these 93
and see how it goes yeah okay
so basically we're completely swamped
all hands on deck i don't even work in
this building don't care i need anyone
with a pulse and a brain to pitch in ron
you need help with anything
no we're good thanks in fact you can
head home early
right now the four of us are gonna divvy
up all these meetings just make them
feel like they've been heard understood
yes sir burt macklin fbi
on the case
april you take leslie's office andy
you're in the conference room and take
your meetings in the courtyard just sit
there and don't
ruin the city
dismissed
what are you doing
can i get a badge
how are we doing
pretty good i may have promised a new
aquatic center to somebody is that a
problem i diagnosed two melanomas
they're both benign how many more
meetings 20.
april was supposed to be the moat that
kept the citizen barbarians away from
swanson castle instead she blew up the
castle and stabbed me in the face
i hired you to do one thing
just one
i don't care that you text all day and
sleep at your desk in fact i encourage
it but only because you were doing that
one thing
keeping this crap
off my desk
give me five minutes before the next one
today i am meeting a potential client on
the golf course because ryan put me on
probation
you remember ryan he was the temp here
yeah
and uh it is not a good time for me to
lose my job since i have some pretty big
long-term plans in my personal life with
pam that i'd like her parents to be
psyched about so
i am about to do something very bold
this job that i've never done before
try
peace offering
are those the flowers i picked up off
the floor of the garden center
yes
they're beautiful trash flowers
look i'm sorry
okay i have been having a long day
ten years of long days actually
you know
i
stock these glow stars
every single year for the back-to-school
sale
and then i take them down and i put up
the halloween inventory and then
thanksgiving and christmas and
valentine's day and easter and fourth of
july and then back to school again
that sounds incredibly not fun
i see why you love it here
it's a good job
but tomorrow is gonna be just like today
and i know that because today is just
like yesterday
so
sometimes
it's just kind of hard to find those
moments of beauty
i know you've been working on picking a
name for the pigeon mascot for uh
several months now i feel like you might
need a breather uh so i've prepared an
eight-point presentation on community
engagement we'll get you a presentation
raymond it's on the agenda
it says here it's scheduled quote after
everyone leaves unquote and not a minute
later trent bryce where are we with the
name we've narrowed it down to two
choices petey or paulie with all due
respect that pigeon is clearly a ray j
hi
gina linetti the human form of the 100
emoji
i'd like to hear captain holt's thoughts
on her name very well my thoughts are
who cares give us a name raymond weigh
in on this it's your job now
no
a name peter paulie which is it what
does it matter why'd you even choose a
pigeon anywhere it's a terrible mascot
because they're a staple of new york
they're non-threatening and they're
everywhere carriers of disease and they
eat garbage name the pigeon raymond you
can't make me i can make you and i will
name the pigeon that's an order
paulie
thank you
was that so hard
april
did you call me i did call you good ears
chris's assistant went back to
indianapolis so he's borrowing me for a
few days
yay
i'd like you to get me some more
post-its i'd like them in multiple
colors are that green i'd like yellow do
not buy orange
i do not want orange i have plenty of
orange
got it
you want 5 million orange post-its
that's hilarious
oh what i have a post-it
for you
this is a great job
um
great job
there you go
stanley may i talk to you for a second
stanley hudson
you are fired
are you serious
i am serious we are all serious
you are fired like a heart attack you're
firing me
over three words
have you lost your mind
do you think i'm going to let you do
this to me
i've watched you screw up this office
for 10 years and i'm filing a lawsuit
and i'm going to tell them about every
stupid thing you've ever done up in this
office right all right okay you know
what
now you know how i feel
this was a fake firing
lesson learned good work everybody very
nice
so i'm not fired that's it
and uh
do you have anything to say to me
oh yes i do
you are out of your damn little
pea-sized mind what is wrong with you do
you have any sense at all okay do you
have any idea how to run an office yes
every day you do something stupider than
you did the day before and i think
there's no possible way he can top that
but what do you do you find a way damn
it to top it you are professional
you